how was your weekend and he just curious
oh it's great I hung out with my kids oh
and I
I met someone really nice on fate okay I
don't know what that is what's fate you
know fate that new dating app I I'm I've
never heard of it no well I just did a
commercial for him Billy can you roll my
ad for fate look at those two first date
no first faint hi Andy Richter here for
faith the fastest-growing dating app in
the country fate stands for [ __ ] and
then eat buffet engaged in sexual
activity before going out for lunch or
dinner
so they can enjoy the meal without
worrying about what comes later
just swipe left or right on the kind of
food you like and fate will match you
with a sex partner that likes that food
too what I'm on a thing I don't have to
wonder if we're gonna [ __ ] because we
already did with sex out of the way I
can enjoy my chili dogs not a fate I
could drink as much as I want because
it's not going to affect my direction
later because he already performed oral
sex on me my down below won't smell of
garlic bread and [ __ ] what are you
waiting for join the millions who
switched from dating to fading
[Music]
[Applause]